sure okay welcome back everyone
uh for the last talk of our workshop so
last but not least of course elias jaco
nicolas is going to tell us about recent
developments in supervised learning with
benign noise taken away
yes all right so i hope you can hear me
so thanks to
seb adam and all the organizers for
inviting me
so i'm going to talk about a recent
progress on
robust supervised learning in high
dimensions
with a focus on something that is called
the benign
noise so i'm going to clarify what this
means soon
so at a high level i want to address you
know this generic question so we want to
develop efficient algorithms
for supervised learning in high
dimensions when we cannot trust
at least not fully the data that we have
so this is a you know
ancient problem so it's coming from
statistics before computer science
existed
so the classical motivation statistics
is something that's called model
misspecification
so the model that you assume that
generates the data your statistical
model
is not going to be exact it's going to
be at best approximate so if you design
an algorithm
for the algorithm to be potentially
useful it needs to be robust from some
kind of deviation from the assumptions
that you made
so uh like in terms of practical
motivations there is something that's
called data poisoning
uh so so this is a
phenomenon that appears in the machine
learning system so it's a general
weakness a general vulnerability of
machine learning systems
so it arises when we have data fed into
our system
that we cannot fully trust for example
let's say we have a system
the data is going to be collected from
various users and some of these users
are malicious so they cannot fake data
for example
give us noisy labels to manipulate
the system so this is a big problem in
recommendation systems like amazon
more generally whenever we want to make
decisions using crowdsourced data we
have to be
careful uh okay now let's uh switch
gears
uh and uh formally define uh the setting
so this is gonna be a statistical
learning sharing and
i'm going to clarify quite soon what i
mean by robustness in this talk
so the model is going to be the pac
model so the standard model for binary
classification
so what's the setup so there is a known
class of functions this called graphic c
so this class is assumed at least in the
noiseless case to contain the function
we're trying to learn
uh this is the target function and what
we observe so what's the inputs
so the input is a set of labeled
examples x y so these examples are drawn
from some distribution d
okay so x is uh the example y is the
binary label of the example x
now the distribution uh of examples
those are these d sub x in the slide is
fixed
but in general it can be anything and
the learner needs to work for any
distribution that's important
so this is what the term distribution
independent learning means so this was
the original definition of park learning
by valiant in the early
80s so there is also the distribution
specific setting where we have some a
priori structural assumptions
on the data distribution uh and i'm
going to talk about that
in the second part of the talk now the
label
uh the y corresponding to example x
is equal to f of x where f is the target
function in the class c
and the goal is to find the hypothesis
with small error
so in particular this this probability
that h of x
is not equal to y i'm going to call that
misclassification error
right now this version of the pac model
is called the realizable pack model
and the reason for that name is because
we are assuming that all the examples
are consistent with the target function
the label
correctly uh now let's see what part
learning with massage noise is so
massage noise model is going to be
uh the uh the main noise model the main
benign noise model will focus
on this talk so the setup is the same as
before
but now uh the label of each example
is flipped with some small probability
so this is this eta of x
that you see in purple now this
probability can
depend on the example x in general it is
unknown to the learner so we don't know
what e of x is for every x the learning
algorithm doesn't know this function
it functions it can be chosen
adversarially and the only assumption
we're making in this massage model
is that this function of x is bounded so
there is some parameter eta
which is less than half which we may or
may not know we don't need to know it
such that eta of x is going to be at
most eta for every x
and the goal is the same okay we want to
find the hypothesis that minimizes the
classification error
all right so let me compare this model
this massage model with
some other well-studied noise models so
basically representing two different
extremes
so first of all there is this random
classification noise model
uh so this is a simpler model where
every label is going to be flipped with
probability
independently okay the independence is
important so okay with probability
exactly equal to eta
okay so this is clearly a special case
of massage
and the second more challenging model is
the one
it's called agnostic and in this model
an adversary can
arbitrarily flip an arbitrary data
fraction of the labels
at least that's the intuitive definition
the real definition is what you see in
the slide
now the massage model lies in between
the two
and the point is that it is a model
where at least to some extent
there is a sweet spot between what uh
sort of we can do efficiently and at the
same time having a realistic model
okay so that's going to be the point of
of
the first part of the talk so again the
first part of the vlog is going to be
about understanding the possibilities
and the limits of learning with massage
noise without distributional assumptions
in the second part of the talk we'll
explain that we can actually do much
better
when we do have some kind of assumptions
about the underlying distribution
hey elias sorry for the
slightly in the weeds question but how
is there a way to compare massage noise
with say you know this probabilistic
concept or p concept noise where
you have you know you could you have the
prob
you have the you know y is still a
boolean label but the probability
that y is equal to one conditioned on x
is equal to it's like mean zero noise
you know
right so is this model that you're
referring to something that's
that's sort of um defined for binary
classification as well or is it for real
valued
um i think the original model is for
binary classification because the label
y is always boolean but there's some
real the conditional mean function is
real valued
so you know the probability that y
equals one is equal to
you know some condition on x is equal to
some real valued function of
x so if it's 0.99 then probably y is
going to take the value one
it's a but you know so you could think
of it as sort of mean zero noise
because because you know what the
conditional mean function is
i see so do we know how to learn how
spaces in this model
well um depends on what the conditional
mean function is
i see okay so let's take this offline
i'm not sure how it's compared to how
massage compares to this uh to this
model but i think
it's a it's a good question it's clearly
known okay just not known to me because
i haven't worked in this model
all right so sorry for the kind of
industry no no no problem that's a good
question
all right so i think that was a good
actual time for a question so now let's
move on to
part one so distribution independent
path learning with masala noise so
really the
the sort of slightly technical part of
the talk is going to be able to have
spaces and then we're going to talk
about marginal concepts
at high level uh so
the sort of motivation for looking at
distribution independent learning
is um exactly that so like recently
you know there's been a lot of work on
algorithmic high dimensional
robust statistics so this is learning
both supervised and supervised without
versailles corruption let's say you
assume that the constant fraction of
your data
is uh arbitrary in some sense now all
the algorithmic results that have been
developed in that in that domain
they need to make some assumptions on
the clean data for example
the clean data comes from a well-behaved
distribution like a gaussian or locom
cave or something like that or a
distribution of whose moments you have
control of
so and these types of problems
especially for the unsupervised
learning center they become hard very
fast when
you have arbitrary distributions so the
motivation
here at least in the in the restricted
sort of binary classification setting
whether we can actually get something
reasonable something algorithmic
uh for natural classroom functions
without making any distributional
assumptions
right all right so conceptually we're
gonna see that
that you know this is possible at least
to some degree
so it is possible to get algorithms
with some non-trivial guarantees and the
main result of part one
of the talk that i'm going to tell you a
little bit about how the proof works
uh his joint work with um christos
jamuns who is at madison
and the famous gulakis who is now in
germany at mpi he was my postdoc when we
were working on this
uh the result is the first polynomial
time algorithm for let me have spaces
in this model are there
non-distributional assumptions
so let me clarify what every term means
here so what i have spaces
again this talk is not for experts so i
have to define objects that are known to
some of you so how space are boolean
functions
whose two classes have a linear
separator so this means that there is a
hyperplane separating the positive
examples from the negative examples
so a half space can be expressed in this
form as you see in this box so it's a
sign of an affine function
so w is called the weight vector so this
is the normal vector to the separating
hyperplane
and theta is called the threshold so
throughout this talk i will assume that
theta is zero
so this is without loss of scenario
before the distribution independent
sharing
now these functions are everywhere and
have been extended extensively studied
in machine learning
all right so we have many names have
been started since the perceptron
algorithm since the 50s
now how hard is it to learn have spaces
in all these different noise models so
there are two questions to ask
question number one how many samples do
you need so this is very well understood
so sample complexity is never a problem
so polynomial many samples in the
dimension and epsilon
are always enough to achieve the optimal
error
on the other hand computational
complexity can can differ a lot
based on the model so if there is no
noise in the realizable model the
problem is easy
so it just boils down to linear
programming
when you have random classification
noise so this is the simpler model where
the noise is independent and uniform
uh it's it's challenging to to say
something but
the problem is still solvable in
polynomial time there is this very nice
paper by blam frieze cannon of impala in
the 90s that does that
on the other hand so the under head of
the spectrum for the agnostic model
even weak learning is hard so again this
is in the distribution independence area
you cannot even get error better than
half
if the optimal is very close to zero
and what is sort of has been unclear
until recently what happens with masala
noise
okay so for this intermediate model we
didn't have an answer until last year
so in fact even for very special cases
of this problem so
even for let's say ores of boolean
variables
the problem has been open it has been it
has been started
for a while mostly with questions we
didn't have any answers
um so
uh like even the following very basic
question
was was open so even if we were given
some
examples from uh corrupted examples from
uh
from the junction and or of boolean
variables
and the eta the upper bound of the
massage noise is one percent
we didn't even know how to get 49 so
like slightly
uh non-trivial and uh so basically
that's the summary of the distribution
free setting prior to the work i'm going
to to describe
and i should say very briefly that if we
make very strong distribution
assumptions about the inputs for example
let's say that the x is our
uniform over the sphere then there have
there has been progress
in the past five years and i'm going to
talk about this progress in the second
part of the talk
all right so here's the main result of
the first part of the talk so we give an
efficient algorithm for linear spaces
with massage noise
and the error of the algorithm is eta
plus epsilon eta is the upper bound
on the noise rates the running time is
going to be polynomial in the dimension
in one over the accuracy so this is the
excess error over eta
and this parameter b and this b is just
the big complexity of the examples
as we're assuming we're observing real
valued
points all right so before i give you an
idea
of about how this algorithm works so let
me make a few
short remarks so first of all the
algorithm i'm going to describe
is not proper so this means it does not
output the half space
instead it outputs something more
complicated which is a decision list
over here spaces and we're going to see
why second
the error we get is not optimal there we
get it
there we get this eta plus epsilon as
opposed to opt plus
epsilon now what is this quantity opt
opt is the best possible error we can
achieve by in half space
and it's not difficult to see that for
this model it's going to be the expected
value over x of eta of x e of x is our
noise back function
and of course instead of x is at most
eta point wise
opposite most leader but of course opt
could be
much smaller so ideally we would like to
be competitive with opt
but we don't know how to and i'm going
to explain why um
towards the end of the first part of the
talk
all right so now let me give you some
intuition
first of all are there any questions
about the the statement before i move to
explain stuff
so if not let me move on
all right so some intuition about the
problem so this slide
is mostly pedagogical so most of these
things
should be known to you if you work in
machine learning but if you if you don't
then you know you may sort of you know
they may be useful
so to make things simple i will assume
for this slide
that the data is well separated so this
means that all the examples
that we observe have distance at least
gamma from the separating hyperplane so
you can see this picture
that there is this slab of of with gamma
around the true separator which is
defined by w star and this slab is empty
now this parameter gamma is known as the
margin okay and the optimization here is
assumed to sort of take place over the
unit ball
all right so let's think how we would
solve the problem in this case
so first of all without noise so uh in
general
what we would like to solve is the the
empirical risk
minimizer so just take the expectation
of the zero one loss
so in this case the objective function
we want to to
minimize is this one this l01 so what
does it say it says that if
y and w dot x where w is the weight
vector you're optimizing over
have the same sign then i don't pay
anything
in cost in loss and otherwise i pay
something
so in reality basically this is what's
happening i take the function of minus y
w dot x and i apply step function so
this blue function
uh now we cannot just directly solve
that it's an unconvex problem
uh so the first trick in the book is to
use convex aggregates and indeed this is
something that works
in the noiseless case in fact uh this is
what perceptron is about so perceptron
is basically stochastic gradient and
descent on a specific convex arguments
and the specific convex argument that we
use that we replace the zero one loss by
is the value function okay so this is
the value
so literally the perceptron algorithm
is sgd on this loss function this is
convex we can optimize it
all right so uh again to see that this
works
note that uh the vector w correctly
classifies
x if and only if the label y has the
same sign
as the inner product w dot x okay so by
the definition of this value function we
suffer positive loss for
incorrectly classified points and zero
loss for correctly classified points
all right now let's see what we do for
random classification noise
so uh so again a lot of classification
noise means
independent uh independent flips of the
labels and the noise is uniform and eta
is the probability of misclassification
so in this case we're going to correct
slightly the relu function and this
works
uh of course we cannot use the value
anymore as it is it's very easy to see
but because we have a very specific
noise model
we know the expected effect of the noise
exactly point wise for every x we know
exactly the probability of
misclassification
uh so the correction we apply that
instead of using the
instead of using the relu function we
use something that's called the
leaky value so this is this function
and this leakage parameter lambda which
corresponds to this
slope of the negative part
it's basically roughly said to eta where
it are now is
is the upper bounds on the on the uh
where it is
is uh is um the flipping probability for
run classification noise
so i'm not going to explain why this
works in detail but roughly speaking
this leakage parameter is needed to
account for the fact
that the label that we observe the y is
not always correct
it's incorrect with probability exactly
equal to eta
and intuitively this loss function what
it does is it penalizes points
which are misclassified proportional to
the distance from the corresponding
hyperplane
while it rewards points that are
correctly classified at a slightly
smaller rates
as without compared to to sort of the
the rail case
so long story short in both these cases
in both the case of
no noise in the case of random
classification noise there exists
a convex surrogate l that is actually
minimized at w star it's minimized at
the optimal weight vector
so we can just solve this convex convex
optimization problem by grading descent
and get the answer all right so let's uh
uh
let's uh uh go to to uh to the massage
case so let's do something new
so it's natural to ask if something
similar can be done for the massage
noise case so unfortunately this turns
out to be impossible
specifically we show that no convex
aggregate works with massage noise and
this means that
for any convex argument there exists an
instance where the optimal solution of
this aggregate will have this
classification error
50 percent so the comics are approached
at least superficially
seems completely useless and of course
the next question is
is it at all useful can we use it to any
extent and we show that it is in fact
useful but in a slightly different way
so in particular if we consider the same
optimization problem as in the random
classification noise case so the same
convex aggregates
um so the leaky value would like a
leakage parameter
approximately equal to eta where now eta
is going to be the upper bound of the
massage noise rates
and then we take the optimal solution w
hat
so this is this red line in the picture
then we prove the following lemma that
there exists uh some threshold t
with the following property that if we
look at this region rt
so this is the set of points uh whose
distance from the separating hyperplane
is
large is at least t then we have two
properties for this region
first of all uh this region has
non-trivial probability mass so it's
probability other distribution is going
to be
at least epsilon times gamma gamma is
the margin
epsilon is the excess error we're gonna
get and
the error of w hat in this region okay
not overall
within this region is small it's going
to be at most ita plus epsilon so that's
like the sort of main structural
lemma okay so
we have what we have so far so even
though convex aggregates do not work on
the entire domain
there exists a convex aggregate that
gives a good hypothesis
on an unknown subset s of the domain so
this subset has a specific shape
it is the region outside the fat
hyperplane
so the algorithm goes as follows so that
so we just use the classifier given by
this convex aggregate
on this subset s okay and we iterated on
the complement
okay and um since the probability mass
of this set is not too small
after the polynomial number of
iterations uh we have
an accurate classifier on the entire
domain okay
and maybe one point i didn't emphasize
enough that even though this set s
is is unknown because it basically
amounts to searching in a given
direction
it's a one dimensional problem we can
literally brute force it okay and find
such a region
all right so this concludes the overview
of this algorithm for the case of large
margin
are there any questions so far
all right so let me move on so i'm not
going to go into the proof of this
but basically i want to convince you
that it's short so basically to prove
the structural lemma we have two
individual lemmas
and each one of these lemmas actually
fits
in a slide okay that's it in terms of
the proof
now let me move on to the general case
okay so far we have described an
algorithm
under the large margin assumption
so in the general case the margin could
be really small it would be
exponentially small in the dimension or
even zero
so how do we handle the general case so
the idea is to reduce it to the large
margin case
to do that we can use techniques from
prior work
so this is not done in a black box
manner but you know it can be done
so a way to do this um is with a
technique
from a paper by paula so here is the key
lemma
from their work so i'm going to spare
you from the formal details
the idea is that we can use a
pre-processing routine
to slightly modify the data distribution
and guarantee a weak margin property
so in particular this means that after
we do this preprocessing
there's going to be an explicit margin
parameter let's call it sigma which is
not going to be too small it's going to
be inverse polynomial
in the dimension and the b complexity
such that if you take any hyperblame
it's going to have at least a
non-trivial amount of mass
a distance at least sigma from it
okay so we can actually use that and get
an algorithm for the general case now if
we actually do that if we use this tool
from dynagraven follows what we did in
the first paper with crystals and uh
femi's we actually get a sample
complexity
that is a scales polynomial not only
with a dimension but also with the bit
complexity of the examples
which in general is not something that
we want for example if the examples have
too many bits
in fact you know we know that we don't
care about running time
we don't need any dependence on being
the sample complexity
and so let me close the section by
mentioning that in very recent work with
christos and danny kane we have been
able to devise a different reduction of
the general case to the
margin case that removes completely this
beta dependence from the sample
complexity
all right so that's concludes sort of
this
this part so let me close the discussion
about half spaces
in the distribution independent sharing
with some very recent follow-up work
so recall that the algorithm i just
described
is not proper it doesn't output a
hash-based hypothesis it turns out that
this is not inherent
so building on these ideas uh a very
nice paper by chen
uh color moitra and yao they recently
gave a proper learning algorithm for the
same problem achieving the same error
guarantee of eta plus epsilon
moreover the same paper by observing a
connection
to the correlational statistical query
model
show that if you want to do exact
learning if you want to get error opt
you need super polynomial time in the
statistical query model so this is a
broad family of algorithms
um that uh you know basically
you know uh almost all we know uh uh
in in the uh pac learning of boolean
function setting
all right so from this latter result
from this hard result we know that exact
learning is hard so a natural question
is
how about approximate learning for
example what if you want to do all of
opt error
or some function of ops uh more recently
in a paper with
with daniel kane we were able to show
a strong statistical query lower bound
in this setting
which basically a result any constant
factor approximation to opt or even any
polynomial factor approximation so if
you want to have
an error of o of ob to the constant
let's say this constant could be very
close to zero one over one thousand
this is actually something that requires
super polynomial time
in the sq model
uh so to summarize so we have described
an algorithm
for this airing for half spaces that
achieves error eta plus epsilon
okay where eta is an upper bound on the
noise rates
and we have some hardened results so
basically the status of the problem is
this we have this line
which basically represents the error of
classifiers so half is the
error of the op of the sort of trivial
classifier
opt is the best thing we can achieve so
eta
is an upper bound we can achieve by this
algorithm
so this is sort of the limit of current
algorithms as far as we know
uh from the very recent hardness result
we know that basically
all vote error or even polyopt error
is not achievable in polynomial time for
sq algorithms
really there is a region here where
we don't know the answer sorry the main
open question is that
is whether there is a polynomial time
algorithm that achieves
misclassification error that's like
any function of odds it's actually any
relative approximation
so let's say g of opt where z goes to
zero with ox
okay so this is a challenging problem
that i would like to see results
so still you know the situation is a
little bit disappointing because
constant factors are not possible
impossible and polynomial factors
are impossible but still something
better than ita
uh could be achievable and i do think
that something better should be possible
all right so this is the end of the
story regarding how space is
it yes i have a question just to clarify
in the sq lower bound
is the value of exponentially small so
uh what do you mean by exponential small
we can get this to be
basically anything that uh it can be
exponentially small in one parameter
in the dimension let's say no no no in
fact
in fact if of this inverse polynomial in
the dimension the problem is solvable
i see okay even in the agnostic model so
imagine that opt is a very small
constant
let's say let's say eta is some constant
okay
it is one-third and opt could be eta to
the hundred
okay so then we don't know how to
improve on either
okay okay so yeah op cannot be really
small effort is really small as a
function of the dimension
then then the problem is easy
i think that's not quite true i mean our
uh
lower bound does not rule out algorithms
to get like
one in log opt or something sure sure
but in any case like
the point yeah we cannot really rule out
the difference between eta to the
hundred and either
but in any case in this law in this
construction the opt
is not too small okay it's not i mean
it's not it's it's bigger than
it can be maybe one over log dimension
but but
not one over poly dimension
okay so uh so it is true that there is
still some gap in
our understanding for example if someone
asks us
is there an algorithm that achieves
error eta over two
if the optimum is it over a thousand
we don't know that we don't it might
exist the gap that we establish in that
reduction is not close to it it's
somewhere else
but it still can be made the dimension
independent
all right so that's what i had to say
about this uh
about this part so uh let me move on
so okay so this is the end of the story
of all half spaces okay and the next
question to ask is
what can we say for other families or
functions in some sense the algorithm
that i described
at the high level is close to a boosting
algorithm
uh so and you know and this sort of
motivates looking at boosting algorithms
in this setting so
so let me give you the word shortest
introduction to boosting
so what's a boosting algorithm it's a
method it's a technique
that combines the outputs of learning
algorithms that have low but non-trivial
accuracy
and uses them somehow to obtain a
hypothesis that has higher accuracy
so the usual setup is that we have a
weak learner
so this is an algorithm that achieves
low accuracy but works under any
distribution
so a boosting algorithm runs a weak
learner as a black box
on many different distributions these
distributions are that
adaptively constructed and at the end it
combines the outputs of
all these weak learners into a final
hypothesis
so boosting was introduced by shapira in
his thesis
in 1990 and has become
one of the most studied areas in machine
learning uh not only
theory but practice as well and uh you
know there has been a lot of work on
boosting i cannot
summarize it here we understand it very
well in the realizable case
even in the presence of noise uh you
know their
algorithms in particular for the case of
random classification noise there's a
very nice
methodology like alliance video for the
case of agnostic
noise there are various papers but in
the case of massage noise there has been
no progress
um so uh in collaboration with
uh with uh russell palazzo daniel kane
lex uh rex lay
sorelle and christos drama so lay and
sorel are students
at san diego so we recently gave the
first posting algorithm for distribution
independent master learning so the
algorithm
perhaps unsurprisingly it's stuck at eta
plus epsilon so it takes any weak
learner
with any non-trivial guarantee and it
boosts in polynomial time
to a learner with error eta perception
where again eta is the upper bound
on the massage noise ratio basically
this matches the guarantee
of the algorithm for her spaces we had
before
and interestingly this ita is a lower
bound
for black box boosting algorithms so we
have a construction like that
i think at this point this completes the
first part of the talk on distribution
free
learning so if there are any uh
questions i'll take them now otherwise
i'm going to move on
to the distribution specific setting
all right so we're ready to move to the
second part of the talk so this is a
distribution specific learning
uh so so far we have seen
that we can efficiently obtain some
non-trivial guarantees but certainly not
optimal error guarantees for massive
learning in the distribution free
setting
so this motivates looking into broad but
not arbitrary
distributions of the examples and see
what's possible there
okay so we want to be able to say
something for structural distributions
that is probably better than what we can
say for arbitrary distributions
so this is the distribution specific uh
setting so the goal in this setting is
to obtain error
opt plus epsilon one times zero plus
epsilon with respect to the levels
let me note here very quickly that if
you want to achieve this error of opla's
epsilon
in the agnostic model even under
specific distributions let's say even
under the gaussian distribution
this is something that requires time due
to the polygon over epsilon
okay so basically to get an improvement
over what is possible
in the in diagnostic model we need to do
better than this
and in particular we're going to sort of
insist on algorithms that are fully
polynomial
that have running time that's polynomial
in both d and one over epsilon
all right now in the massage model in
particular
having an algorithm that gives you error
of plus epsilon with respect to the
labels
is basically equivalent to approximating
the true classifier
that you started from the base optimal
classifier to any desired accuracy
okay and this is going to be the
guarantee the goal we're going to
achieve now
we want to find an h such that
the error of h and f where f is a true
function goes to zero
okay it goes arbitrarily close to zero
and note that
this type of equivalence between oblast
epsilon's classification error
and the epsilon uh error with respect to
the true function
is only true in this massage model in
the agnostic model it's not possible
to actually approximate the optimum to
arbitrarily small
error all right now i guess this
equivalence is a simple calculation in
the master model
all right now in the distribution
specific setting there are several
polynomial time algorithms the
literature
developed since uh
by 2015 in papers by
was the balkan and collaborators so in
particular we we did know a polynomial
time algorithm when the distribution was
uniform over the sphere so very well
behaved i mean these things could easily
be modified for the gaussian
distribution but then if we generalize
the distribution a little bit
for example we consider the same problem
over the broader class of log concave
distribution so we don't know the exact
distribution anymore but we know the
family
where it belongs then the algorithm that
was produced by this group
was a little bit unsatisfactory in the
sense that its dependence
in this parameter one minus two eta
which sort of the gap of eta from a half
was very bad it was like doubly
exponential
all right so so the question is okay can
we get a polynomial time algorithm for
this
more general class of lock and key or
more ambitiously
for broader families of structural
distributions
so in the recent work with christos and
our students vasilis condominius and
nicos arifis we made some progress in
this direction so specifically we have
identified the family of distributions
uh that we term well behaves for which
an efficient learning algorithm is
optimal error
okay so it is uh is actually possible
so i'm not going to formally define what
well-behaved distribution means here
but roughly speaking the property that
we need
is that uh if we take a two-dimensional
any two-dimensional projection
of the data then it will have good at
the concentration and satisfy
reasonable tail bounds in particular
these properties that we need
are actually satisfied for for local
care distributions and various
generalizations with heavier tails
so as an immediate corollary we actually
get an efficient algorithm for
distributions as well
and let me also know that the concurrent
work by zhang and awasti
obtained a different polynomial time
algorithm for the special case of the
local gear distributions
all right so that's a theorem so i'm
going to give you a few minutes of
description of how this algorithm works
before i move on to stronger models
uh okay so some intuition about this
version of the problem so now we have
distributional assumptions
so the question is how can we actually
use them to do better
than in the distribution free case so
let's remember what we want to solve
so what we want to minimize is the
population risk so this expectation of
the step function of minus y w dot x
so we suffer loss of one if y
and the inner product of w dot x have
different signs and loss of zero
otherwise of course you know this is not
something we can
get our hands on and actually solve it's
highly non-convex
so let's again try to see what we can do
with convex arguments with convex
relaxation
so let's take the step function and try
to replace it by a convex function z
we had seen earlier that this is
something that really fails
in the distribution independent setting
in fact it also fails in the
distribution specific setting
so even for gaussian data
you cannot use comma targets to get
to get near optimal error so our idea
okay is to replace this uh
zero one step function by a non-convex
function
that's gonna be a smooth approximation
to to
um to the zero one function to the step
function in particular
so this type of logistic loss here is
one possibility we can use many other
things so let me give you a picture
so this is a step function and this
smooth approximation is this logistic
loss
so that this function has a parameter
sigma which basically quantifies
how close this logistic loss is to the
step function
uh so ideally sort of each sigma is not
too small
like if you solve this sort of
non-convex problem then this would be
good enough
but of course it's not clear to have
made any progress here because
uh like there is no reason to believe a
priori
that replacing the zero one function by
some non-convex
relaxation is better than the initial
non-convex problem which is actually
exact
so algorithmically why is this useful in
particular
it's can we even approximate the global
optimum of this new objective
and the answer to that
is that we don't really need to
approximate a global optimum
uh in particular the main structural
lemma that one can show
is that any point that has small
gradient
is good enough for the purposes of our
learning problem so they have this lemma
i'm not going to
read the out loud so more formally like
if the parameter sigma is sufficiently
small
you take any weight vector w which is
the normal vector to the
unknown have space that has non-trivial
angle
from the optimal one that this point w
needs to have a large gradient
with respect to this function so
assuming that this structural lemma is
true
we as a corollary we get an algorithmic
result in particular we can use
any first order method that converges to
stationarity
and get you know an efficient algorithm
for our learning problem in particular
you can just use sgd
projected i guess so this is the
algorithm so run sdd of this non-convex
objective
so really the difficulty is showing that
this suffices in particular proving this
structural lemma
so let me give you an idea of how we
actually do this
so uh so for simplicity we're going to
look at the two-dimensional version of
the problem
it turns out that this is without loss
of generality we can always do that
and uh to make things even easier
i'm going to assume that the
distribution of the domain is the
uniform distribution on the sphere
so here is the picture so what we have
here we have
the green half space which is the
optimal half space w star this is what
we're looking for
and we also have this black vector w
which is a candidate have space that we
assume has a large angle from w star
and what we want to show is that w
we have a large gradient okay
uh so so one observation here is that
since we're optimizing over the unit
sphere if we look at these gradients
they're not going to have any radial
component so the data component is going
to be zero
so it's going to be it's going to be a
vector perpendicular to w okay
so the goal is to show that this vector
is non-zero
okay if the angle is large and
sort of an intuition here is that when
we run sgd we draw a sample from the
uniform distribution of the sphere
and then we update according to the
gradient of that point
x so if you do the calculation you'll
see that there are two kinds of points
in this in this problem so there are
these blue points
and these are points whose gradients
actually point to the right direction
they point left
so this is the direction of the optimal
half space so these are the good points
so these are the points that help us
prove our lemma and we also have these
red points that point in the opposite
direction so these are points whose
gradients point
away from the optimal half space
now since the distribution is uniform it
might look like uh you know since the
area of this blue region is much larger
than the area of the
uh red region we're good right so we're
done so
uh unfortunately this is not true so it
turns out that um
the noise decreases the contribution of
the blue region by a factor that goes to
zero as ita goes to half
so a factor is going to be something
like one minus two eta
so eta is the upper bound of the noise
rate so it could be the case
that the gradient contributions of the
blue region in the red region cancel out
and the lemma is false so the way we fix
this is by using this parameter sigma
that quantifies the approximation
between these logistic laws
and the 0 one step function so this is
the
the basic parameter of our non-convex
surrogates
and uh so when we pick sigma to be small
enough
you know hopefully not too small because
this affects the complexity of the
problem
so what we are doing we're essentially
reweighting the samples
so that only samples that are at
distance roughly sigma from the current
half space so they have space defined by
w
which is the current points will have
non-trivial contribution to the gradient
so the picture
looks something like that when we have
this sigma parameter
now observe that in this case the ratio
of the blue region
and the red region restricted to this
slab
increases as sigma decreases so for
small enough sigma the blue region will
have much larger contribution of the red
region and therefore
the gradient of w will be the gradient
of w will be large
so overall by picking this parameter
sigma to be sufficiently small
as the lemma says we can rule out any
hypothesis which has large angle
to be an approximate stationary point
and that basically
is you know the entire proof
are there any questions about the proof
of disclaimer if not i'll move on to the
next topic
all right so in the past in the last
let's say maybe five ten minutes uh i
will give you a flavor of how to go a
step further
so the question is are there even more
challenging benign noise models
to more challenging than massage for
which we can get efficient algorithms in
the distribution specific setting
so recall that the massage model assumes
that these probabilities the flipping
probabilities are uniformly bounded by a
parameter eta
which is strictly less than half so
unfortunately this
assumption of bounded noise fails to
capture
a number of uh sort of realistic noise
sources that
that are important in practice for
example this includes
the case where the data is annotated by
humans so this is called
human annotation noise so and you know
there are many other settings for
example
when the noise rate becomes larger
when you're close to the separating
hyperplane or when
maybe the sort of classification is
close to random in
areas where the density is very small so
there is a stronger noise model in the
literature
that allows the these flipping
probabilities to be arbitrarily close to
half
and this call is called tobacco noise
model here is the definition
so it says that if you take a point x
then the probability that the noise
function at x
is bigger than half minus t this sum
parameter
grows as some function of t to the alpha
this parameter alpha is basically
sort of as it goes to zero the model
becomes more
challenging all right so this c back of
noise model has been very popular in the
learning theory community
especially with statisticians has been
extensively started in the past
two decades so the motivation for
starting
from sort of an algorithmic perspective
is because it actually
provides a unifying framework to capture
this situation that i
just mentioned where sort of the noise
is not bounded
uniformly from above now in terms of
sample complexity the model is fairly
well understood
okay so polynomial domain sample suffice
for most concept classes that we care
about but the algorithmic question is
much harder
in high dimensions in particular until
like recently
there was no non-trivial algorithm even
under the gaussian distribution
on data so in very easily work with the
same
co-authors with condonis and zarifis
so we're able to give a quasipolynomial
time algorithm
for optimally learning of space in this
model so the algorithm
recovers the optimal hub space within
error epsilon
and runs in time that is quasi
polynomial in epsilons like d to the log
square
one over epsilon
so this is the first improvements over
agnostic learning
for this problem now let me briefly
explain
why learning this model is more
challenging compared to
compared to the missile model so at a
high level the idea
or the difficulty i guess is the
following so recall
that this previous algorithm for massage
noise we described
restricted its attention to a small band
around the candidate hypothesis w
and we looked at the intersection of
this band and the disagreement region
between
let's say the candidate have space and
the optimum space
now if we do the same thing with the
tobacco noise
then it is quite possible that all the
points in this region have probabilities
like flipping probabilities very close
to half just by the definition of the
model
as a result the useful signal that these
points provide may not be strong enough
to overcome the effect of the remaining
points so basically these
techniques inherently fail in this model
so how to overcome how do we overcome
this obstacle so i'm going to give you a
sort of
very high level description of what we
do so we're going to look at an easier
problem so i'm going to give you a
candidate
w a candidate vector i'm going to ask
you to certify
if it's far from the optimal half space
w star
and the idea is that sort of we can view
such a certificate as a non-negative
weighting
of the points so in particular we have
the following simple fact
so the proof is a simple calculation so
it says that if um
a weight vector w is far from w star it
means it has large angle
then there exists a non-negative
function
t t of x such that this expectation
of t of x times y w dot x is actually
negative
uh and of course now this should be
straightforward if you think about it
for a minute
because you can just take t of x to be
the disagreement region between w and w
star
right like on the other hand if you take
w
to be the optimal half space w to be
equal to w star then this expectation
is not negative for any non-negative
function t
so in reality this means that in order
to certify
non-optimality over weight vector w
it is enough to find such an on-negative
function t
okay that makes this expectation
negative and when we have
such an algorithm to find such a
function t then we can actually use it
essentially in a black box manner to
approximate the optimal half space so we
can reduce
the learning problem to this easier
certification problem
now the way that this reduction works it
could be
either sort of viewing this type of this
type of certifying algorithm as a
separation oracle
or by using online convex optimization
you can pick and choose
so really the difficulty is to find the
function of this form
okay like you can you cannot just use t
of x to be the disagreement region
between
w and w star this is intractable to
actually find
so so here's the lemma
that appears in this paper so it says
that in order to certify non-optimality
and again this is for the distribution
specific sharing so it it explicitly
leverages properties of the underlying
distribution and then it suffices to
consider
these regulating functions d of x that
are not arbitrary but they have a very
specific form
in particular essentially they're going
to be of the form
square of a low degree polynomial times
um the sort of the characteristic
function
of of a band close to w so this is going
to be our function g of x
so the this this lemma tells us
that um there exists a polynomial of law
degree of degree something like
logarithmic in one over epsilon such
that such
certificate actually exists and in fact
we can compute it in time that is
that scales as d to the k right so there
are two parts improving this so part one
is to show
that such a polynomial exists and this
is something we can do using
chemistry polynomials and
algorithmically
we can find it using sdp okay we can
solve a semi-definite program to check
this condition over all squares and
polynomials of degree at most k
all right so overall this leads to a
quasi-polynomial time algorithm for this
problem so the obvious question
is whether a polynomial time algorithm
exists
and the answer is yes so so this is in a
variant paper with the same authors plus
daniel kane
now to achieve this to to get a
polynomial time algorithm
we use the same overall framework the
same certificate breast
base framework but we need a much more
sophisticated algorithm to find
such a certificate
all right so this concludes the
technical part of the talk
so let me uh summarize so so what did we
do today so i described
a line of work a recent line of work
that sort of
in my opinion is sort of a fair sort of
step
in restarting this field of like
learning with sort of benign
models of noise so it's a part of a
broader effort
to develop a general theory of robust
learning high dimensions
uh so basically the uh so the conceptual
points is that
it is possible to get some non-trivial
error guarantee
for natural classes of functions in the
distribution independent setting
in the presence of benign noise but
unfortunately there's still some
limitations
and if we make assumptions about the
underlying distribution we can actually
get optimal learning algorithms
right so in terms of future directions i
mean there are many i mean there are
some of them are obvious
for example you know we mostly talked
about have spaces in this talk so what
happens for more general
cluster functions i mean the two obvious
generalizations here would be low degree
polynomial threshing functions and
intersections have faces
a conceptual question is whether there
are
other natural models of noise so
semi-random
noise models in which we can learn
efficiently
either in the distribution-free setting
or under weak assumptions about the
distribution
uh in terms of housing results if this
is like your cup of tea
so the only evidence we have so far for
hardness of these problems are in the
statistical query model so if you come
from path learning
as i do this is a sort of satisfactory
answer if you want reductions then would
be an interesting question to see for
example
can we actually obtain reductions from
some problems that are believed to be
hard in the average case or maybe can we
prove
uh some squares lower bounds all these
things
should be doable we'll have some ideas
in these directions and from a practical
standpoint it would be nice if these
types of new algorithms
could have some practical implications
for example in data poisoning
so for those types of applications i do
not expect any
end-to-end guarantees any theorems but
maybe some of the
insights of these algorithms can be used
to per to to sort of
improve practical performance all right
so at this point
um you know
i'm done and i'm happy to take questions
okay thanks any questions for elias
i guess i have a question i mean you
sort of touched on this at the end but
maybe you could speculate on um
if if there's some natural relaxation of
the
independence assumption for these noise
models
right right so i mean one can relax
independence a little bit
but um we do not know exactly to what
degree
in particular like one way to use a
massage model
like which is not the exactly equivalent
is that you have an adversary that has
full control on a random a uniformly
random it's a subset of the data
it's a fraction of the data okay so this
is not sort of an independent
setting
right right and all algorithms have been
developed work in this
slightly stronger setting as well now to
what extent
we can we can actually relax
independence is unclear so this is an
interesting direction for
future work so in reality there's a
continuum
of semi-random models that interpolate
between a random classification noise
and agnostic
and we don't know what the answer is for
most of them
so what i gave you this is like really a
snapshot of what we can do for two
specific models and for specific
classroom functions
got it um great
um also elias maybe if i don't know if
you're planning on making your slides
available but when you
kind of briefly went through uh the
massage noise
and you said oh you know these lemmas
fit on one slide
you know people might be interested in
looking at those slides it just flashes
flashed by it
yeah this is why this is why the slides
are in so i did give a talk
somewhere let me remember okay at cmu um
this might be online we'll actually
present this proof but this was like a
one hour talk that uh focused only on
the first part
of this um of this talk but in any case
yeah in any case these slides are gonna
be
you know that's why they're in there
they're gonna be in my uh you know in
the slides that i send
and um in fact there's like the proof in
the slides is complete
it's like slightly simpler than what is
in the initial paper
great great
okay well thanks again elias for um
you know wrapping up the whole workshop
here uh on a high note
and uh thanks to all the speakers and
contributors
uh it was an exciting week and i hope to
see everybody in person
at some point at the simons institute
in a in the near future
thank you bye